welcome to the forum live streamed
worldwide from the leadership studio at
the Harvard th Chan School of Public
Health I'm Dean Michelle Williams the
forum is a collaboration between the
Harvard Chan School and independent news
media each program features a panel of
experts addressing some of today's most
pressing public health issues the forum
is one way the school advances the
frontiers of Public Health and makes
scientific insights accessible to
policymakers and the public I hope you
find this program engaging and
informative thank you for joining us
welcome to today's forum on the health
and economic concerns of rural Americans
I'm Joe Neal I'm a deputy science and
health editor at National Public Radio
NPR and I'll be your moderator today
we're going to be discussing a wide
range of concerns that rural Americans
told us about in a recent poll that we
conducted with the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation and the Harvard Chan School
you're going to be hearing some
surprising results today from that poll
and I hope it will lead to a spirited
discussion we're also going to talk
about some innovative solutions that
could help out many rural communities
and I should also point out the next
Thursday November 15th is National Rural
Health Day so it's an auspicious moment
that we convene this panel before I go
any further let me introduce our panel
our distinguished panel starting from my
immediate immediate right is Bob Glendon
bob is a professor of health policy and
political analysis at the Harvard Chan
School and the Harvard Kennedy School
next to Bob is Ted Strickland Ted is a
former governor of Ohio to Ted's right
is David Terrell
David is executive director of the
Indiana communities in Institute at Ball
State University and also of the rural
Policy Research Institute's Center for
state policy and next to David is
Katrina badger Katrina is Program
Officer for the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation this event is being presented
jointly with the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation in the Harvard Chan School
we're streaming live on the websites of
NPR and the forum and we're also
streaming on forum and YouTube I'm sorry
on Facebook and YouTube we'll have a
brief Q&A at the end so there's still
time for you to email your questions the
address for that is the forum at HS pH
at Harvard sorry the forum at HS PHS
harvard.edu you can also participate in
a live chat that's happening on the
forum site right now
now to our panel the poll I mentioned as
rural Americans what they see is the
biggest problems in their communities
today we ask this toward the end of the
summer in over several weeks we expected
to see that jobs in the economy would be
among the top concerns and we did indeed
find that but we were also surprised to
see the magnitude of concern about
opioids and drug abuse the federal
government has recently expanded funding
for drug prevention and treatment as you
may know and so we wanted to bring you
the government's point of view first
about that program and what it is aimed
to do so we'll have a clip now from the
US Department of Agriculture
every day about a hundred and
seventy-five Americans died of drug
overdose and the majority of these
deaths are caused by opioids the opioid
epidemic is truly the crisis next door
it's really like pushing a boulder
uphill and with the addiction crisis
we're seeing kids as young as nine years
old that are using that's the population
that we're losing 15 years ago if you
told me that we were gonna have to have
a drug task force and tactical response
team at Green County I looked at you and
told you you're not we can no longer
pretend that all over America is Friday
Night Lights
there are a lot of challenges in the
rural areas from a transformative
standpoint there's got to be modern
connectivity from healthcare access
telemedicine to many other types of 21st
century needs
this issue is a very high priority for
the administration secretary Purdue
really sees this as more than a health
issue this is a matter of rural
prosperity in these communities working
together we will end this stigma of
addiction defeat the opioid epidemic and
overcome the crisis next door
of course that was a clip from the
federal government's US Department of
Agriculture well no we we will no doubt
be hearing more about that response in
our discussion today and rural America's
views toward getting outside help from
various sources the federal government
state governments and/or other
organizations but first let's find out
more about the specifics of the poll Bob
what what are the main findings
so first the survey is quite unusual
it's aimed at giving voice to people's
lives so it doesn't ask about the
country it asks about your own life your
kids and the community to live in so all
the questions are about that
and so the findings are surprising if
you're in the polling world you rarely
ever see people say that the biggest
problem in their community is a health
problem and that's the opioid thing is
just quite unusual and my colleagues
here said I don't know we did expect
this but actually it's not this is very
very unusual if we can have the first
just PowerPoint we'll do these very
quickly so this is again people are
asked in their own words no list or
anything what is the top problem in the
community you live in and as you could
see opioids and drug abuse and economic
concerns are top and in Appalachia I've
been trying to learn to pronounce it in
the middle western way for that
it's the overwhelming problem so this
epidemic which ten years ago you just
would not have been discussed moving
away through one in four people we
interviewed knew somebody personally
that was suffering from opioid and drug
abuse and the second thing is economic
concerns which is what most people if
you watch the elections that people talk
a lot about and we are talking about
people when asked about their the
community they live in fifty five
percent of them said the economy where
they lived was fair poor so these are
people looking across the street and not
seeing very hopeful point of view but
Minh you actually talk to people so
if you follow the national news and no
disrespect to some of my colleagues
there's an impression that everybody is
despondent living this community so we
just have the next PowerPoint so it
turns out that half the people living
there believe that these very big
problems can be resolved in five years
there they are much more optimistic and
the other half don't so a big critical
issue is again when you interview in
rural America there's a great sense of
self reliance on neighbors communities
church groups and you ask people are you
going to need outside help and you
actually expect the answer is no we are
going to deal with this it turned out
when you think about opioids and the
economy the answer is yes so most of the
people who thought something he turned
around wanted outside help and the next
PowerPoint is is a surprise if you
follow politics you would have sort of
expected that they would have thought
private groups or companies or something
would be where the outside help that's
what they would want and basically six
out of ten people said we expect to have
the outside out principally from
government a state was the largest but
essentially this is a political
environment that isn't very high on
government but when it came to their two
top problems they actually expect
government to play a much larger role at
for it and I think that's what the panel
is going to discuss about what it is
they couldn't do and the last is we took
a number of reports which had governors
and commissioners on we'd said how do
you turn around life in rural America we
just gave them a list and said which
ones are the most important a last power
point so what you have is that the top
two are something which would create
long term job opportunities and was very
clear people are not looking for
short-term startup some jobs for WPA
they want something that really sticks
and the second thing is they want
something done they would help their
schools out the next year
people check a box called improving
access to healthcare and if you don't
follow it and you talk to people it's
usually three things so in this case
they're worried about their words going
on there so that Falls secondly they're
worried about medical groups that they
went through last year they're not going
to be there and thirdly a sheer rural
America doesn't have enough health
insurance to pay their bills and that
falls and the last is and the pounds go
to discuss this people know they need a
set of skills to be viable economically
ten years from now I don't think they
know what those skills are they just
know they need something so that is the
really big takeaway the opioids is an
incredible finding if you surveyed
across America that just doesn't usually
show up but the priorities economically
and the fact the they're so concerned
they're want to know what's the other
sources of government that's pretty much
the take away but they didn't know how
to go beyond this to solve the problems
they faced thank you Bob
so what you're saying let me just follow
up briefly what you're saying if you did
a national survey of all Americans
opioids wouldn't show up but when you
focus in just on rural America like we
did in this poll it was a surprising
find you know when you ask people about
the top problems facing the country it
does not show up as the top problem
anywhere it's on a way down or a list
now people think about their own
communities differently so for it but it
just it you would expect it on a list
where you ask people now tell me about
your health problems you would think
that was ranked high not that when you
would face everything else the community
would face it would be tied with
economies which have been depressed my
name for for many years so this epidemic
is having an impact on how people see
things locally which is just not been
recognized unless you're very close to
these communities well that that leads
me to Ted you were Governor of Ohio and
you saw firsthand the impact of opioid
abuse and other drugs of abuse the loss
on rural communities tell us about your
experience well coming from Ohio and
especially growing up in Appalachia I I
was not surprised at these results
nationally according to the CDC in
nineteen or in 2017 we lost about 72,000
Americans to drug overdose deaths in
Ohio today we are losing about fourteen
people per day and the sharpest increase
obviously has been in in most recent
years the use of fentanyl and synthetic
opiates so it's a huge problem I think
it's a national public health problem
and in my judgment it hasn't been
sufficiently recognized as such so I'm
not surprised with your results bob
i-i-i i believe that rural areas have
particular problems when it comes to
these kinds of issues both healthcare
and economic opportunities we need
treatment
we need medically assisted treatment we
need long-term treatment we need trained
treatment professionals but there are
other aspects to this problem that are
related but equally important housing
issues transportation issues food
insecurity problems all of these are
characteristics of rural areas
especially the Appalachian area and I
think at least tangentially if not
absolutely directly related to the to
the opioid problem recently we had in
Ohio a ballot initiative which would
have dramatically changed how
individuals who were apprehended
arrested for drug offenses would be
handled that they would be dealt with
locally they would not in most cases be
charged with a felony and initially
there was strong support for that and
then questions came about regarding how
it be implemented in and whether or not
it would be good for
state the bottom line is it failed in
the most recent election but I am
absolutely convinced that that both
political parties and an array of
Ohioans recognize that at least the way
our state is dealing with these problems
need to be really given careful thought
because when a person is caught up in an
addiction there is no there is no quick
easy answer a treatment effective
treatment tends to be long and arduous
there are relapses and and it is
affecting and we're going to hear more
about this I think from David it's
affecting the economic conditions in all
parts of Ohio and that's certainly true
in the Appalachian area well I think our
poll did show that the - well it didn't
show but it highlighted that the two are
very interconnected and David you've
studied what it takes to reinvigorate
local economies what have you learned
about what does and doesn't work well I
think that first thing we need to
address is there is a train of thought
and I think it's a very valid train of
thought that the opioid crisis is really
a symptom of a lot of other deep-seated
issues including the economy the local
economies and there are several reasons
for that and while we can't ignore those
that the symptoms of not only the opioid
crisis but other public health issues in
rural communities we really still need
to understand and deal with that root
cause of the local economies and for
many many years decades that default
mechanism is the mindset that if we just
create jobs that'll solve our problems
and the evidence is showing that this
enterprise of the business attraction in
and of itself is not the panacea for
communities there are a lot of other
deep said other issues that when you
didn't deal
and we're not saying that job attraction
should go away that activity should go
away it should be dealt with and pursued
maybe at different levels but you can't
have successful job attraction and
unless you have strong viable
communities and and the bottom line is
is the evidence is showing that jobs go
to where the people are it's not people
go to where the jobs are
that's switched somewhere in the 70s and
the trends are stronger and stronger as
we move on jobs go to where the people
at the booth are people want to live in
viable communities that have a strong of
civic infrastructure strong physical
infrastructure and strong and robust
schools the research shows that time
after time strong robust schools are
critical that along with along with
those other infrastructure components
and as an aside we are finding that
people will pay for that
when you talk about tax issues but
that's another issue for sure Katrina
your work at the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation focuses on issues that affect
health and well-being in rural America
and community development what do you
see in these poll results and what do
they suggest to you about how to move
forward so in addition to the issues
that have been already discussed quite a
bit I think with the opioids and
Economic Opportunity needs which are
certainly important I want to make sure
that we elevate one other finding that I
think is really important from this poll
which is the importance and strength of
social connection in rural communities
across the country and we know from
research that social connectedness
between families and neighbors and
neighbors looking out for each other and
helping in times of need really leads to
better health and longer longer lives
and better health and well-being then
those folks that are facing greater
social isolation and so that social
connectedness I think is a really
important find
to elevate from this poll although it
doesn't stand out as highly in some of
the the top findings that that get a lot
of the national attention and I would
also elevate that that social
connectedness is really important and
connected to economic opportunity and
economic mobility so for example if we
look at Raj Shetty's data from the
opportunity Atlas and some recent
studies that have been that have been
looking at that data folks might assume
that kids that grow up having better
opportunity than their parents have been
thus having greater economic mobility
what might be coming from urban and
suburban areas but actually generally
speaking rural youth are have greater
economic opportunity than in other
places and that is in large part because
of better social connectivity and job
matching which really points to the
strength and opportunity of local
solutions local policies and solutions
that drive that opportunity thank you
before we move to our open discussion
the next part of our hour here with you
all today I want to set the stage with a
short clip about improving opportunities
in rural communities in innovative ways
the clip comes from the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation and it shows how
business owners in Allen County Kansas
which is not far from where my family
settled way back in the 1800s I should
point out are addressing the needs in
their community we're going to hear
first from a man named Joe works Joe
works has a servant's heart in 2010 when
the national economy was in recession
his company BMW trailer hitches saw a
dramatic drop-off in sales
what Joe chose to do rather than lay his
friends and neighbors off he put them to
work in the communities I think the
desire to give back to the community
came before BMW I think that was just
part of the way our family was built and
that's something that's contagious that
is influenced ray Moloney INLA harp I
have a recycling center and we do
everything from aluminum cans to
combines if it's metal we'll buy it well
I looked around the area and decided
that we needed some workers in around
here you know people that knew how to do
things with their hands so he put his
money where his mouth is by buying a
former lumberyard complex and donating
buildings on that complex so that it
could become the regional world
Technology Center well it took some
prodding you know to get this thing
going so when we go through here we're
gonna have our 21 inch boards run past
our 17 inch boards well right now we
have construction trades going on
sponsored by Fort Scott Community
College thanks to a grant from the goth
group Neosho County College is on board
with welding I know we have 20 kids in
the construction program and I know
there's both classes of welding or full
okay like 27 and the welding is yeah
keep the jobs here keep them here that's
what we're hoping to do train kids and
try to keep them home well that's
particularly important in a county like
Allen County which has lost about a
thousand people over the last decade
it's down to about 13,000 people it's a
very sparsely populated part of Kansas
Katrina can you talk more about the
rural Technology Center and other
innovative programs like we just saw in
the clip yeah well I would highlight
that Allen County is is one example and
we've we've elevated through our culture
of Health Prize several communities and
actually many rural communities that
bring to life different solutions
that really address social and economic
opportunity and advance health so I
think they are great local stories to
learn from there are a few other
examples that I'd like to lift up as
particularly promising models that that
could be learned from one is project ago
which is at elementary program was
originally designed to provide expand
access to specialty care for hepatitis C
tella mentoring being providing training
over to professionals in very specific
specialty areas and it was originally
developed for hepatitis C but has been
expanded across many different issue
areas and that started in New Mexico it
did and it's gone across not just the
country but across the world and has
expanded outside of health care issues
into things like special education and
different specialties and right now it's
being used in 30 states across the
country specifically to increase access
to quality care for treatment for opioid
addiction and drug abuse and but I think
it's it's a very useful model to expand
and it's an evidence-based model to
expand a issues and and care specialty
across rural areas in particular but
aside from thinking about health care
models and and and health care settings
in particular I also wanted to elevate a
group of organizations that's working
across rural America they are calling
themselves the persistent poverty
working group and it's a group of
community development institutions and
economic development institutions across
the country that are working in the deep
south to close banking deserts as we
talk about food deserts there are places
that nobody has access to a bacon
counter or credit there folks working
along the us-mexico border and
unincorporated areas to provide
solutions that counteract predatory
payday lending and actually provide some
access to to credit in those ways and
folks working in the center of the US
and Arkansas and the and the south to
address some
the greatest infrastructure needs around
water and sewage that you can't do much
development in a community if you have
sewage running down your your streets
and and folks working to increase
capacity and and increase access to
affordable and quality housing for
example and Native communities across
the country and in Central Appalachia
and so I think we've seen that these
organizations that are working at
regional scale across jurisdictional
lines across issue areas across racial
ethnic groups have found solutions that
work in those places and so if there are
ways that national or state or or other
folks can can connect to and support and
enable those local solutions that are
already that are already underway and
showing a lot of promise and could just
use more enablers David you and I were
talking before we came in here today
about automation and the link between
automation and opioids is there a link
we think there is and just to give a
quick explanation that works the we need
to understand employing the mix of
employment people actually working jobs
in rural areas the largest component in
the largest percentage of people working
still primarily work in manufacturing
and that's around depending and
especially in the survey area and we're
looking at Appalachia Midwest and South
it's still around twenty-five to thirty
percent of the workforce works in
manufacturing or some components of that
and that's diverged more than the rest
of the states if you look at the
employment mix it's probably around ten
percent or less the rest of the state
works in manufacturing or statewide less
than that so you see a preponderance of
still in manufacturing and then we also
have to look at
jobs job losses and there's been a lot
of news the last couple of years about
that but the fact of the matter is
different studies show different numbers
but really anywhere from sixty to eighty
percent of job losses are really due to
automation not due to offshoring that's
due to automation and we estimated
closer to the eighty percent number and
so that's that's there so we're also
taking a really hard look at occupations
that are vulnerable to to automation and
also occupations vulnerable to
offshoring but the the bigger risk for
occupations is in the automation up to
sixty percent in a lot of counties those
occupations are vulnerable to automation
and that the concentration is in
manufacturing so you have manufacturing
in rural communities vulnerable
populations to to automation and the
segment of the population that's most
vulnerable or the the segments that have
the least education that the studies are
proving us out so you can see it and
then we've also just published a study
that that does show just the stress of a
threat of automation as spiraling
impacts on the family and on the
community so these are all real
challenges the community has to face and
so that is you know you know we're just
exploring what this all means but a very
quick answer is robust education and
looking at those kinds of things so
that's a quick explanation of the
impacts of automation I just want to
follow up on the study you just talked
about when you said that just the stress
of automation coming how are people
aware that that's about to happen I mean
is how did you measure that the the way
it's I mean you we know that the we know
the automation threat is there people in
the workplace are aware
of the automation it's a threat it's the
way it's treated they see equipment come
in and they think well that's time it's
my turn mm-hmm and it's it's a very
visceral we were talking very modulus
cars - and driverless starts and
driverless trucks and that that's
another policy issue that that really
folk forces us to understand yes there
is a tactical need for example truck
drivers there is a tactical need and a
lot of states and communities are
putting millions of dollars into
training for truck drivers but we also
know that strategically we are going to
get driverless technology sooner than
later and so what are we doing to
address the tactical need that
strategically preparing that workforce
for whatever other job demands might be
out there and I'm wondering if we're
paying enough attention to that
strategic imperative of really
well-rounded training and education
basically learning to learn or that
broader set of skills that the you know
the reasoning skills and comparative
analysis skills the critical math skills
and those types of things I want to get
to opioids in a minute but before I do
Ted one one solution that's often talked
about is and tried our economic zones
and tax breaks in various states you
know how is that working is that a
viable solution still doesn't have an
effect you know I think part of the
problem is that we tend to try to
compartmentalize the answers to the
complex problems that we face and when
it comes to economic development and
when it comes to health care and when it
comes to dealing with the opioid crisis
I think we need to understand that we
need a more comprehensive holistic
approach I would use the phrase provide
wraparound services it has been
estimated that
in terms of rural healthcare and this
this data comes from the nationalization
of state offices of rural healthcare by
the way they say that about 20% of the
healthcare related problems are
attributed to access to healthcare about
30% can be attributed to behaviors
health behaviors and perhaps up to 50%
as a result of socio-economic and
environmental factors and so I think we
need an approach that is that that
understands the breadth of the problem
and I would I would try to illustrate
that by just sharing with you a an
experience I had a few months ago I was
driving on a cold day from Columbus Ohio
to Athens Ohio to teach a class
I passed a fellow standing alongside the
road hitchhiking I stopped and picked
him up and we chatted as we were driving
along he told me he was trying to get to
drug treatment he told me he had just
recently got gotten out of prison he
told me he was alienated from his
daughter and he said to me you know I
wish I had a car because if I had a car
it'd be easier to get a job and you know
I think about that fella a lot I share
that story a lot because here's an
individual who has a life situation
having been caught up in drugs having
gone to prison having gotten a felony
which makes it difficult to get a job
once you're out of prison not having a
car having to hitchhike to drug
treatment on a cold winter morning and I
think you know I think he illustrates
part of the problem that so many people
in rural areas face there are
transportation difficulties job
lack of job opportunities lack of access
to technology we were talking earlier
about so many communities not having
access to broadband technologies and and
and and and so I think I think we really
need to not focus just specifically on a
person's drug behavior but I think we
need to look at at at services that
provide support many people I think most
people who do get into drug treatment
have periods of relapse and and so a
short-term answer is is not likely to
solve the problem we need to look at
this problem holistically
comprehensively and and understand that
there are there are many factors that go
into a person's getting caught up into
this kind of addiction and many factors
that go into their efforts to get out of
this and and and to live a healthy life
well we saw in the the video earlier the
government's pouring more the federal
government is about to pour a lot more
money into treatment and prevention yet
Bob you and I were talking about public
support for treatment is actually fairly
low what do we know about public support
for that kind of treatment that that
governor Strickland is advocating so in
the middle of an epidemic there's a lot
of public support at the moment for
throwing some money at this but there's
not a great deal of understanding of
what the it is so large share of the
public thinks this is a short-term
treatable problem and so it's some time
they're gonna wake up and find out that
this is very long-term and want to know
why about that an issue of race later
but let me raise it very quickly because
it's very worrisome in the long term we
asked in another survey people about how
would you measure the success of
treatment
and the number one thing was well going
back to work well those of you familiar
if you are recovering alcoholic you are
protected by federal and state laws your
employer if you've slept can't fire you
at the moment a very large number of
employers do not have to rehire you back
and can easily fire you if you slip back
so we're talking about in the public's
mind spending hundreds millions of
dollars and you're gonna go back to work
but we haven't found the employers that
are willing to take people who tested
positive on a drug issue so we're at a
point of view this is a crisis that
people want to spend money on but
there's not an understanding about Ted
said about the long-term nature of the
treatment what they are for this and
also the employment implications if
we're going to solve rural America
people have to go back to work and they
have to be protected if they're in
treatment so you could find a public
backlash three or four years down the
line if they think this is something
that's close to antibiotics three months
of treatment you're back when in fact
it's not and that is just the worrisome
thing you don't see it on the front
because the president said it's crisis
let's spend money on it but it could be
three or four years from now if there's
not a better understanding and also if
people who are in treatment can't go
back to work that could be a very big
political issue but isn't the arc I'm
looking at a question we have we got
from online isn't the arc of in our
political system right now you the three
billion dollar expansion notwithstanding
isn't the arc toward more
criminalization or supporting more
punitive measures against producers as
well as go the other way around
they do that they're closer to the
governor oh they are so we actually
compared attitudes towards when we had
the big cocaine and other outbreaks and
they're all shift the majority of people
say treatment and not prison that's
different if you're saying you're
selling large sections of it but there's
been incredible even though and that's
the problem they don't know what the it
is but they've absolutely decided by
filling people filling prisons office
night is not the answer so they're
definitely been a societal shift
the treatment well then why did the Ohio
measure fail so badly
well it was it was probably not crafted
as as it should have been but the idea
behind it is as a sound idea I believe
and I it is my hope that the Legislature
will you know will take this up but if
we can prevent people from getting
felony records if if we can deal with
them at the local level rather than
sending them to a state prison if we can
have an array of appropriate data-driven
medically assisted treatments if if we
do those things I think we can have an
impact it is it is very very difficult
I've worked in a prison for a temper of
years as a psychologist it is very
difficult if you have a prison record
and you're looking for a job
it just is and and we have massive
numbers of our citizens now who who have
felony records and and and so the idea
is to is to try to recognize that these
addictions are are are medically related
medical conditions and I think one of
the reasons Bob that you say that people
are now more big shift shifting toward
treatment rather than prison is that it
has impacted so many people and and
we're talking today about rural Ohio and
and you know and maybe some of the more
economically distressed areas of our
country but but this addiction problem
has affected every strata of society and
I think more and more individuals are
coming to recognize that if they aren't
at risk as an individual their family is
at risk their neighbors
at risk and and we're not going to
punish our way out of it we we need to
provide appropriate treatments before I
move off of opioids and drugs our poll
found in rural America somewhat to me at
least surprising number of people who
said they had been personally affected
by the opioid crisis and we should not
forget
Methos resurging and main part of the
country what did what did the poll find
so you had one in four people who were
somebody that they really knew what for
there is an age difference yes I mean
younger people are much more frequent a
quick clarification many people
particularly if they're older can
separate out the type of drug that
you're using so in Kansas meth is a much
bigger issue and people were worried
well they didn't say meth people just
say my god they have a drug problem
they don't go down and look at what the
test results are so but this explains
why we lumped all of these because it
was an open end equation and so people
want exactly what is the brand that
they're addicted to absolutely and
people know very much personally and
they're very worried about it because
it's spreading among people that they
really know and without getting whether
or not it causes the economy or others
it's just very hard to envision
economics things coming back if you
somehow together can't get that under
control because it's so spreading across
so many communities right let me turn to
another question from the web before I
go to the audience
Roger Valdez I hope I have that
pronounced right his director of Seattle
for Growth wrote in and said in
Washington state whorl counties have
higher levels of poverty lower vacancy
rates older buildings lower wages and
higher rates of unemployment however
state level subsidies are going to fund
nonprofit housing construction in urban
areas especially Seattle can you can
someone on the panel comment on this and
discuss a bit about housing and what can
be done to address this growing problem
among people living and working in rural
areas I'll take an attempt at that in
Indiana
which we of course study more closely
but I think this is typical of what
we're seeing there is that there are two
things going on there there is a demand
in rural communities a perceived demand
in rural communities of market-rate
housing that people are talking about
new home construction and and so we have
task forces and different initiatives
trying to address that but we also have
a really really high population or stock
of abandoned homes and he's in these
communities and you could have both at
the same time but what we're beginning
to understand is that huge oversupply of
stock impacts the cut the the price of
the house and in 41 of the rural
counties that we studied the cost of
building a new home is higher than what
it can sell for and unless we deal with
that stock of homes that Realtors don't
count but the market counts that that's
that's one of the first things we have
to do so communities are trying to get
ahead of that and trying to deal with
that stock first so that that's from the
market mechanism approach and I know
especially after the are and the the
recession and the the programs were that
there was a lot of effort to deal with
that issue but that's still a huge issue
that we need to deal with and then we
also have to look at different these are
state level issues in community level
issues what kind of tax structures are
inhibiting the ability to
rent homes and you know that could be a
response to a proactive response to
threats with gentrification and we this
is something that it's kind of like the
jobs issue we know there are issues
there housing is an issue but there are
so many layers we have to uh that we
really need to understand hmm all right
do we have any questions from the
audience please wait for the microphone
which Lisa mera what's our great
producer is bringing there you go
hi my name is Leila Romani I'm a program
manager here at the Chang school I
really commend Bob Strickland what you
said on the approach to address us not
with incarceration but with dealing with
this issue locally I have a question for
both of you actually
what research has been done or
conversations have been had about this
change in mentality of how to approach
this issue compared to minority
communities elsewhere in history in the
US and the fact that incarceration was a
big part of addressing the crack
addictions in the 1880s how could it has
that been a frank conversation I think
what you're referring to is some people
believe and I think correctly so that
when the crack epidemic exploded that
was a very hard line a lot of people
were incarcerated and and you know our
drug laws and our punishments have not
always been consistent I mean that was
obvious in the discrepancy between crack
cocaine and powder cocaine for example
and now there does seem to be a shift as
bob said and maybe he can speak as to
why he thinks that has occurred more
toward treatment less toward punishment
I would hope that that's big
we have come to realize that punishment
and the approach that we've used in the
past it's not worked very well I hope
it's not because as as some believe that
it's the kind of population that is most
caught up in the current epidemic versus
versus the populations that were most
associated with the use of crack cocaine
I can't argue I understand your question
and and I I cannot give you a definitive
answer I don't know if Bob would we
simply say that but we have to be
straight and honest minority communities
believe that the first epidemic which
impacted them much more greatly got a
different response from the president
down to this epidemic which is much more
widespread demographically people say
well it's only an epidemic affecting
white Americans turns out Latinos rate
this is a very very serious concern we
can't answer the question but from the
president down in that other epidemic
locked them up it was the national
policy and it was supported on the
ground through pulse and now we're the
other way around people want to try
alternatives but you can answers Ted
said is filling prisons you know
thousands thousands of people and the
end of the day it didn't solve it that
could have been as big a factor as oh
it's in one group or another but it just
looks like if people are convinced that
filling prisons and you can find very
conservative communities where the
political leaders are saying we've got
to get out of the prison that's not the
way to deal with this and then when
you're back this other question is Ted
hit well we have to help them recover
and be employed they'll never be
employed again so I think people have
really understood the consequences of
fighting a drug epidemic by putting
built in prison but there's real tension
between minority communities the poll is
elicited comments from people saying I
wish they would have worried in this
other error when it's so impacted Harlem
or here or something like that the
political people didn't talk about it
but there actually has been a very real
shit
right can we have another question from
the audience we're going to go a little
past one o'clock just for people who are
my name is Nam I'm a health policy
student here at the chance school thank
you all so much for sharing your
insights my question is for Katrina you
spoke a lot about or elevated some
telemedicine approaches that are meant
to address some of the accessibility
issues that we've been talking about do
we see this as a real comprehensive
approach or is this more a band-aid to
address you know the real
infrastructural issues with the rural
health system should our money be
diverted towards enhancing that system
or is telemedicine the way forward I
love that you asked that question
actually I think it's really exciting
because I think what we've all talked
about is that there's no single silver
bullet right the opioid crisis is an
urgent crisis that's that folks are
dealing with on a daily basis that we
have to take on and this is one just one
part of how we can take it on certainly
the hospital closures and that the
healthcare crisis across the country is
another issue that that we are working
on and and is important for to be dealt
with but I think also it's important to
elevate what folks have said before
about how healthcare is actually just
one small part also of how we think
about what what creates the opportunity
for folks to be healthy and live long
and good lives and so it's really
important for us also to remember as
we're taking on those those kind of in
our face issues to think about the
social opportunities the economic
opportunities that are really critical
the public infrastructure education jobs
that are that are really critical to and
I think also what what you mentioned
governor is that we have to also
remember I think often as we have these
national conversations we can become
very siloed in our certain issue area or
our certain sector but in real life we
all know that actually all of this is
very much connected we can't talk about
house
without thinking about how that relates
to transportation and how that relates
to access to our job
and how that relates to education and
all of those pieces and so those that
are working on these issues in their
communities and finding those solutions
are that it all weaves together so it's
not just working across sectors and
across issue areas but also across
jurisdictional lines and into regions of
scale so I think just again it certainly
it's not tell it you know telehealth is
one piece we can't do it without it but
it's only one piece thank you I think we
have a few more minutes left for one
more question
looking through them here we have a lot
of questions about opioids of course and
rightly so in this question comes in
from it doesn't say here but when it
comes to the opioid crisis in rural
America pill mills are a huge problem in
West Virginia which I believe has the
highest rate of opioid prescriptions and
deaths we have a pill mill crisis what
regulations can realistically be put in
place to increase scrutiny at the local
state and federal levels to stop this
type of illegal over prescribing by
doctors and pharmacists anyone want to
take that one well we had a huge problem
with pills
I followed what I call dirty doctors
from community to community over a
period of months working with with the
FBI and local law enforcement we were
finally able to to close down these pill
mills Portsmouth Ohio it went time they
say had about seven pill mills and
people would stand in lines to get in
pay is $75 and come out with a
prescription I would just suggest that
your caller contact the the authorities
in Ohio and find out how we did it but
we actually
the pill mill problem hasn't been
totally solved but largely solved in in
in Ohio now but it took it took great
effort and it took law enforcement and
and a lot of time to get it accomplished
I know I see a report almost every week
from states across the country of
another pill mill shutdown so it still
clearly as flourishing well in these
last few minutes I'd like to give the
panel an opportunity to give us one
takeaway message from what you've
learned from the poll what we've
discussed here today and I'll start with
Katrina so I think what I want to
highlight then is something I haven't
heard us talk a lot about today that the
poll did highlight and and we've learned
through our other message testing that
we've been doing a lot of in the past
six months is that it's easy for us to
talk about these issues about opioids
about economic development and Economic
Opportunity and in a way that makes
rural America seem like a monolith and
really what the poll highlights for us
too
yet again is that you know there is very
diverse perspective very diverse
experience very diverse assets and
problems in different rural places
across the country and so as we think
about solutions or needs and priorities
it's really important not just to look
to the findings from this poll but to
connect with the local leaders working
in these places and so that sit down
with data and I'll just highlight a
couple of resources that might be useful
in that is County Health Rankings
provides county level data related to
jobs education opportunity health help
different health issues and housing and
other issues at a county level across
the country and recently we released a
u.s. a leap data which provides life
expectancy at birth for every census or
almost every census tract across the
country and census tract is like the
neighborhood level so it gives you much
more specificity
so I would just elevate the importance
of recognizing that that nuance and
sitting down with local leaders and
local data to identify the priorities in
the individual communities and that the
real importance lifted up through some
of our other research in partnership
with the Noor qual Center and building
relationships and Trust with with folks
in in place so that we're not
reinforcing the narrative about division
thank you David I want to build on that
a little bit but but I think the one
thing that we really need to understand
and it's really kind of in response to
the poll is that the communities we've
observed really succeed are the
communities that own the issues and they
understand and they try to access the
databases and those types of things and
they know that they're going to need
outside help but they they aren't
looking for the troops to come in and my
observation and having worked in state
government is States are more willing to
come into the communities that figure
out how to help themselves and because
they're showing that vested interest in
that and the other component of it
especially when you look at economic
development and also something that's
solving some of these problems
especially in the areas that that we're
talking about in regional areas we
haven't really talked the the
agglomeration of labor markets and the
synergy between communities and even the
rural urban divide it's really not a
divide it's a continuum and most rural
communities in this area are within
commuting distance of either
micropolitan area or a metropolitan area
and they're not little islands unto
themselves and we need to get over that
and that barrier that psychological
barrier of the community as a solvent
for themselves so we need to look at
that and regional approaches to and
where the communities can add value
the region bub well um not talked to we
talked about Ted Bob as long as I can
talk I don't care what you call me so we
we talked about the fact that people in
these areas know they need help a
federal level state that will help and
and local level help and I think that's
really true and I would just point out
that Ohio we expanded Medicaid seven
hundred thousand Ohioans now get access
to health care because of that and much
of the treatment for people who have
these addiction problems is being paid
for through Medicaid and just an example
of how important that is I visited a
small 25-bed critical care hospital in
Appalachia just within the last couple
of weeks
and I was told that seventy-five to
eighty percent of the resources coming
into that Hospital were Medicare and
Medicaid and so I think that's a
terrific example of how states and the
federal government's can work together
to try to help these rural areas deal
with this addiction problem all right
now the real Bob
so surprised when we asked people watch
what should be done there's a big
investment a big belief in doing
something with the schools in advanced
training and technology the real problem
and they would service this what should
they be training their kids for for 10
years from now and I think if we had a
follow-up question they wouldn't have an
answer to that they would say maybe it
shouldn't be truck towers but what
should it be maybe I should be doing
artificial intelligence but if you're
gonna help people help themselves they
have to have some sense of what the
future education we had a significant
number of people who wanted to go back
and get advanced training but I think if
you ask the second question they'd be
scared that what they took would never
get them anywhere and so people are
gonna need advice if you were really
trying to get your local school to make
sure your kids don't have to leave what
is it you'd focus on and at one end you
can have stronger liberal arts at the
other you can have stem programs but I
was really concerned that people look at
training and schools is the answer
without knowing what should be in those
schools that's take away from those well
I want to thank everyone for joining us
today thanking thank our panel for being
here you can continue the discussion on
the forum website the chat is still
going on and that concludes our panel
for today thank you